okay uh good morning everybody thank you
very much for joining me in this talk
today about trying to break out of the
typical scenario of building business
applications in.net Marion focusing on
having a bit more fun
um in terms of the format I've tried to
fill as much of this slot as possible
so try and keep questions towards the
end if we can but I will try to make
sure there is time
um although on the topic of saying that
you might not have time for questions I
I'd like to start by asking yourselves
some questions
um who here has had a great idea for a
game format good
oh
how about now is this any better
more
is this better
a bit better
should I keep talking until we get to a
better level
a bit more
keep going
how about now is this better yep okay
let me start again um hello everyone
thank you very much for joining me
um I'd like to try and uh talk to you
today about breaking out of maybe
building a typical business application
that Dr Miller is typically touted for
and focusing on having a bit more fun
um
I'd like to start by asking a couple of
questions of yourself so who here has
had a great game idea
no fewer than I was expecting
um who has turned that idea into a
actual concept that you could try and
prove
thank you David and finally who he has
uh started on that great idea only to be
distracted by something completely uh
nonsensical and disappearing down a
rabbit hole into building something you
didn't need
um I certainly have my hand up for these
questions that we did as well but um
that's precisely what today's talk is
all about
um let me just quickly get the
introductions out of the way uh my name
is Sean Lawrence I'm a independent
software engineer and I typically work
on functional business applications so
there isn't a lot of freedom to be able
to flex my creative side
um but hopefully today we can break out
of it
I was very lucky to be awarded the
Microsoft MVP this year which I'm sorry
last year now um which relates to the
open source work that they typically do
on Donna Mary Community toolkit and the
xamarin community toolkit uh and a
little bit of what we're talking about
today is uh something called the orbit
game engine which is taking down at
Maori and then being able to build 2D
games with it
and then finally it does claim that I'm
an author but it's currently in
production so if anyone is in
are interested in learning about how to
use.net Maui come I've got May time then
I would thoroughly recommend a book
called Introducing donut Maui
um
so what are we going to cover today um
uh hopefully by the end of the session
you'll learn about two of my great
passions uh what is Dr Maui uh gaming in
general and then how we can then combine
them together into something that could
be fun in terms of
the development process as well as
actually the output a lot of the work
that I've been doing is probably
I don't know if it's quoted David more
about the journey rather than the
destination because as developers that's
what we enjoy
um so we're going to look at what we can
achieve with.net out of the box
um and then look at how we can then bend
it to do what was probably considered a
typical game or lots of looking at a
game engine and how we we would build
that into.net
and then finally there'll be some tips
and tricks to help you avoid any
pitfalls that I have experienced over
the past months
um so a very brief introduction as to
what.net Maui is um if anyone didn't
catch Gerald's talk yesterday he gave a
much more in-depth detail but then that
will be available I think to catch up on
um well like I said this is rather brief
is a cross-platform framework to allow
you to build modern applications and
that gives support for things like
mobile mobile idiom in terms of Android
and iOS
we've then got desktop support in Mac OS
and windows and then through third-party
support via Samsung we can run on Smart
TVs and smart fridges via the tizen
platform
and actually a colleague of me at mine
yesterday Jay sent
a photo of one of the sample games from
this repository running on a Samsung
fridge which is quite impressive
um
uh onto a bit more so uh Jolly Murray is
the evolution of xamarin forms we ended
with xamarin for forms five we've got we
had.mr6 and then we're on to seven
um it is now versioned and released
alongside.net so we get a major version
every year with long-term support every
other year
the evolution does bring a lot of much
needed benefits I don't know if many
people here have dealt with xamarin
forms in the past but um
there were lots of things that left it
lagging behind but now being part of net
officially we get much better support
for things like modern languages so we
can actually deal with latency sharp
features we're not we're not lagging
behind on that and then we've also got
five faster Superior built-in support
for things like dependency injection so
if anyone's built an ASB net core
application you'll be familiar with the
app builder pattern you get exactly the
same thing in Maui I think
belief I have is that it then allows us
to transition between.net code base is
far simpler because we're all looking at
the same kind of pattern
um we've covered briefly what Dynamo is
so now let's look at what a game is um
according to Wikipedia it's a structured
form of play so this could be anything
from a card game a piece of Sudoku and a
piece of paper
um
exploding kittens which is a foam and
family favorite
or even then we can move across to
something like a console game or even
virtual reality Games so it could be
anything that ultimately becomes fun
sadly I'd hoped to get a great quote out
of my children for a game but they've
now turned it into a game of just
hitting me with dictionary definitions
um
so now um there's we've we've covered
what dot ml is very briefly and what a
game is now we can start to look at what
we can do when we combine the two
together
um
there are actually a lot of games that
we can build out of the box so if we use
a typical business application
architecture like mvvm there are
actually there's a number of games that
we can build and here are two examples
of of doing that uh
like I say this this is built
this is actually built with Emory forms
but it is slowly being migrated across
to.net Maui
um and a lot of these functionalities
are
using either built-in support or
third-party packages so we've got
things like there's an animation class
that allows you to
animate your UI make it feel alive to
the users
there's things like Lottie which I don't
know if anyone's familiar with Lottie
but that's really quite fantastic piece
of technology that I fairly recently
discovered
um it allows you to render any form of
Animation in an application and it is
rendered in the application therefore
you get scalability it's not like
embedding an animated gif in there and
you have to deal with sizing issues and
actually bloats because it boils down to
a little Json file so actually it
performs pretty well as well
um
the The Words which app on the right is
closed source which makes it difficult
to then show off the functionality so as
part of the recent work I've been doing
is is taking the key concepts of this
one and then being able to show you how
you can achieve the same things but in
an open source project
um so like I says we've we've got the
ability to animate things you can
there's either inbuilt functionality
with within.net Maui where you can
animate the scale just in a single
method call or you've got the ability to
to dive deeper in terms of building an
animation programmatically
becomes a little bit more in-depth but
um you can really get some quite fancy
effects
uh and then the finally the one that I
really quite like is the little the star
effect that you see when the the tiles
match
and that's um it's not something that
ships with DOT net Maui
um it's actually going down to the
platform specific layer where we can
then Implement a particle system
um and I think one of the big selling
points well I've done it Maori is
supposed to do a lot for you you've
still got the ability to get down to the
layer itself so
on iOS for example we're dealing with a
core animation layer and we're
generating a CIO emitter and then we're
just firing particles off when um
when we're calling it from the shared
code base as well so you can write your
platform specific code and then
encapsulate it enough to be able to then
interact with it
directly from the shared code
um there is a blog post here that shows
you how to do this takes you through
each of the steps I'm not going to focus
too much on this today because actually
there's hopefully some more fun things
that we can start to look at
um but I would like to point out that
uh I wouldn't worry about keeping up
with the links there's a QR code at the
end that will take you to a post that
covers all of the useful links from
today's talk
um
so we have looked at
some of the types of games that we can
start to build uh out of the box so
we're using things that come with Donna
Maui but there are quite often scenarios
when this this approach is not enough
when we start to imagine games with
multiple objects or characters that then
each have their own States things can
become complicated very quickly
um I couldn't quite decide whether this
image accurately represents that
previous statement or whether it's
actually just my mental state after
being on this journey
um
so what we typically what we would need
to do then when we when we could get to
this level or to avoid this level of
complexity we're going to start to look
at what what's considered a typical game
and that is the primary focus of the
talk today
um but before we dig into the how and
the why I'd first like to show you an
example of a game the game that had
inspired this engine and then we can
look at how we can go ahead about
building that
ah
so
um
the great game idea that I came up with
was a little bit of a Twist on asteroids
we've got a planetary defense where
you've got a ship on the right hand side
and you're controlling it in a very
limited manner you you're orbiting a
planet and the idea is you can either
speed up or slow down and you've got a
battery that will deplete when you use
your thrusters
and therefore you've the aim is to
control it well enough that you can then
actually destroy the asteroids that are
coming in to attack the planet
so if we watch it in action
uh we've got the ship we've also if you
notice there is a shadow on the right
hand side so the aim is that if you're
not within view of the sun then you
can't regenerate your power either so
it's trying to add a little extra levels
of complexity
and eventually you'll see that these the
asteroids will collide with the planet
they don't collide with the ship yet
that is something that I'm currently
working on
um
I know you'll get into the level of uh
it becoming too complex and you're
running out of lives
um
it's an interesting one I've gone on
this journey and I suspect actually the
more finders we've actually been in the
building of the the game rather than the
game itself but it's been able to kind
of expose what um Harry has to offer and
what can potentially be achieved with
the technology
um the only other things I'd like to
show quickly just based on uh some
exercises we're going to cover
um
we can start to be able to add in extra
little bits of information because I
mean we can draw whatever we like on the
canvas it's really quite powerful so
when you realize your high school math
is not quite up to scratch
um you can actually start to see why the
the objects are not going where they're
intended
um it did actually create quite a nice
effect at first whereas Randomness in
terms of whether the asteroids were
heading
but they weren't where they're supposed
to be going
um and then um the other thing to note
we are going to have a bit more of a
talk on accessibility as we progress but
um
the thing to consider when we're doing
this is how we want to allow the users
to actually drive the input so at the
moment you click on the right hand side
or touch on the right hand side and
it'll speed the ship up I can show you
that
so I click it speeds up I click it slows
down
then the other thing to consider is
maybe you actually want to provide a
visual buttons for people to click on so
it's a bit more obvious and inclusive
release out there for now
foreign
so on the previous slide and during that
talk I did uh refer to the term typical
game so I'd just like to take a step
back and um explain a little bit about
what I mean by that
these are um games that are typically
built with game engines and they will
involve a rather different way of
working so uh you could consider this
probably the first real conceptual
difference between a business
application and a game
um
where what happens is
uh so a business application will you
typically sit there idle waiting for
user input whereas a game Loop it'll be
constantly looping making sure that
things need to be actioned are being
actioned it should feel fairly familiar
if anyone's worked with a real-time
based system
so that some PLC programming or things
like that where again it's a looping
approach and you're you're given um an
allocated set of time if you exceed that
and you're put on the naughty step you
remove because there's so many
components it needs to have at the time
application
um and we can see here in terms of the
loop what actually we'll end up doing is
we um if we look at the right-hand side
the first step is we'll process user
input make sure we're not blocking uh
then the aim is to update some State and
then eventually we'll turn that state
into something that's rendered on the
screen so we've got the two separate
stays there they're really quite
important and we'll get into the detail
of those
and then finally we wait so then
actually we can get to a point of
providing a continuous a smooth frame
rate so we delay typically 16
milliseconds in order to provide a 62.5
frames per second
um
and then there are techniques so
actually we say well if we know that the
right hand side took six milliseconds to
execute then actually we'll deduct that
from the weight so then actually we try
to provide as smooth the frame rate as
possible
um as I mentioned it's key to try and
not block as much as possible because we
have a limited amount of time to execute
um so ultimately if you're going to take
longer than this you end up going to
introduce lag and then ultimately the
application is going to die and the
users are going to have a horrible
experience
um so now if we look at how this fits
into.net Maui
um some people have asked me why why did
I try to do this uh there are many
answers I'm not sure if I could decide
any are good enough but um I guess the
key takeaways are
in part of building the word search app
I was introduced to skia and I actually
became quite impressed by what that did
so then I took when we then migrated
over to looking at Donna Maori they'd
actually introduced their own API which
is the dynamic Graphics API
what we then did was look at uh I guess
just trying to find out what's possible
um it is I was pleasantly surprised I I
guess
one slightly contradictory statement
that I've come up with is I wanted to
push myself outside of the comfort zone
while actually still kind of keeping
myself as comfortable as possible
staying in some level of comfort and
that comes in the fact that I'm familiar
and comfortable with C sharp and Dot net
Maui
I'm not familiar with the other parts
but that's the bit that I wanted to flex
and try and investigate what's possible
uh obviously there are many other
Frameworks like Unity or Unreal Engine
that will do far more than this
uh but the other key thing that I wanted
to try and focus on is Donna Maori is a
UI framework anyway so there's lots of
functionality that already provides that
you don't need to implement
and should feel fairly familiar when
you're building an application
so the hope is it might be an easier
transition in from building this
business application to just flexing
that creative side of having a bit of
fun and then finally the Journey of
building that demo application that we
saw actually kind of identified some
things that could quite easily be reused
in terms of building my next great idea
So the plan has been to build on top
of.net group the top net Maui graphics
apis for those not familiar with that
it's essentially it's a surface that
allows you to render I say Pixel Perfect
graphics on any platform supported by
a.net Maui we can consider that an
abstraction layer itself just like dot
net Maui in the fact that you interact
with its API and it has its own platform
specific implementation so
being able to draw on on iOS and all of
that is covered for you
um and that to note is as I said during
my investigation on the word search I'd
come to the assumption that Dr Mary
Griffith was built on top of Skies which
it is not
um you can it is entirely possible to
swap it out so they've built that
abstraction layering that you can put
skier under the hood if you don't want
the Maui layer uh but obviously you're
going to end up with
a bigger binary because you're shipping
more dlls and I personally haven't come
up with a technical reason to do that
other than some unit testing side of
things that we're going to look at later
on
so I mentioned that Dynamo provides us
with the two key components we've got
the graphics view which comes from the
Dr Mary Graphics API a surface that lets
you draw on things that's relatively
straightforward and then we've got the
dispatcher so which allows us to
schedule an action are performed after a
time delay
and therefore that's our weight Loop so
we can see how that fits into this Loop
um
the processing of the user input is a
tricky situation because if we imagine
we've got desktop devices we've got
mobile devices we've got fridges I don't
know how you're going to interact with
the fridge
um you get a Bluetooth controllers
connected to any number of different
control schemes you might use the
accelerometer on a phone to as your
input
there's no inbuilt way of just doing it
all for you or no easy way to abstract
that away so at the moment uh
user input in terms of trying to build a
game with this engine it would be
entirely on your own
the in terms of touch support it's
really quite impressive you've got an
extensive number of events that you can
subscribe to from the graphics view
which is entirely available via the
engine because it inherits from this so
everything that comes with automara
Graphics comes with the engine
in the other hope that if new
functionality comes out you can just use
it you don't have to wait for new a new
release
and then because like I said previously
Maui is a graphics a UI framework as it
is so it provides you with no at no end
of ways to be able to build a UI and
deal with that user interaction so you
can you can do it that way
uh the next step in our in our Loop
approach is to update the scene so we
simply
uh update that and we tell it how long
since how long has passed since we last
called you and therefore that means that
if you're dealing with movement
information you can actually use that as
a ratio to calculate a smooth movement
and things like that all relative to
when you were last called
and then the final step on the right
hand side we call render which means uh
we can't convert the state that was
modified in the update method into
something that's rendered on the screen
and in terms of the implementation
detail of what I've been looking at is
we just have to invalidate the graphics
View and that just tells it you need to
go and rejoice yourself
and then the final point in our Loop is
uh
the weight and that's just a case of
scheduling something to be done after a
period of time so that's just calling
back to the same method the code you
can't see here because it wouldn't fit
on the screen is the calculations to
work out how long it's taken in order to
get you to the next step
uh We've covered a little bit on
a little brief detail as to what got me
to the engine and I'd like to show you
actually how you can use it because I'm
hoping that it
will provide you with a platform to
actually go and create these ideas
um I do believe they read me on the
repository provides a decent overview of
how to use it
um but of course if there's nothing some
things that aren't obvious then please
do feel free to reach out or raise an
issue or a PR or anything like that so
correct things
um but much like uh most uh
bootstrapping options now with uh at
least with Donna Marion
um other things like asp.net core apps
we just have to call as a used orbit
engine extension method that will then
register all the bits with dependency
injection ready for you to
uh use all of that goodness
um in order to render something on see
on the screen we have to add in a what's
what's called a game scene View and this
will then actually provide the surface
that you can draw onto
and uh
it can function like any controlling in
dotnet so it you can consider it just
like a button or an image you can put it
wherever you like you can make it as big
or small as you like it doesn't have to
consume the whole the whole page
um and it provides all of the the the
interaction events that come with that
demographics so you can handle all of
your touch input directly in your scene
in your in your application
and modify around um the other thing
that you might note is that because
we're in the orbit game
the the background is static so actually
there's no point in rendering that every
time uh we we go through the render Loop
so that sometimes the optimization is
just just stick an image in because it
never changes so actually there's little
kind of tweaks like that that you can do
to save on some
some effort and of course you can stick
buttons on top again it's all Z or Z
index bass so you can actually control
what goes on top uh if you want to pause
dialogue or a game over message then you
can put all of that into your UI
uh
and then the only other point that has
been under this discussion and it's not
clear whether it's a good option or not
is
whether we completely remove the need of
a Content page and actually have a game
scene page and therefore it'll just be a
full screen
um uh to interview
once we've initialized it and we've put
our surface on the screen we then need
something to render
so um we
we we call this a scene and typically a
scene is any screen in your application
in your game so and and its Associated
state so um what you'll see is in this
scenario it's the home scene so it's
when you first start the application
It's relatively simple actually you
don't need the spawn two methods they're
just there to obviously highlight what
you can do
so you can update state in the scene if
you really want to and you can render
things so in some games there might be a
dynamic background that you want to
change therefore you could do that in
the scene
and then simply it the scene contains
the objects that live in the life of the
game and you can see here we're just
adding a ship of sun and a planet
and they will come through the magical
dependency injection that will
get to see shortly
um
once you've
added your you've got your surface to
draw and you've got your scene you then
need to glue the two together so you you
can actually just call there's uh an
implementation called the game scene
manager that controls the state of the
scene and ultimately the game we have
the load seed method which has recently
gone under a bit of rework and the fact
that
uh we can scope instances there now so
if you've got
an instance of a game object that you
want to share Across the Life of a scene
that's all taken care of for you and
actually we will cover a decent example
of that and then every time a load scene
closes then you can you can tidy up
after yourselves so you don't have to
have Singleton instances lying around
which will continue to
to consume some level of memory
um you get all of the lifecycle events
so you can
start stop the game you can subscribe to
them as well so if you want to show and
hide
you want to show a pause menu when the
game is paused but you're not causing
pause and you can you can interact with
all of that and you
um the loop stops as well when if you
pause the loop is only running when
you've started so
you don't have to worry about other
objects being updated in that in that
regard
uh so our final item is the game object
itself and these are kind of the main
building blocks of a game uh
I've got written down here game object
represents a single object in your game
which is possibly not the best the most
helpful description
um it can be whatever you like it can be
it can be a character it could be a
component of the character it can be an
enemy an asteroid as you can see in this
example um
ideally if we try and apply some level
of solid principles then we'll try and
keep things as simple as possible but uh
like I said it can be literally whatever
you like you can see that we've got the
ability to load an image that's all
built in so you can do that and then at
the bottom we then have the ability to
draw that on the canvas you can tell it
where to draw it
um
and outside how big to draw it and we'll
get into some more detail as to actually
what dynamic offers in terms of the
canvas interaction shortly
um
which is now so let's take a look quick
look at the concepts that can be used in
a real application
here
please do let me know if the code wants
to be a little bit bigger so
massive on my screen
what's it doing it's opening a new
window
um
so as we can see we've got the the use
orbit engine Accenture method that we're
calling and then
as we look further down then we're just
building up some of the dependencies
that we're going to want to use so our
main page has dependencies on things in
the game so we have to register that
then we've got we're making use of some
of the essentials apis with the haptic
feedback and the vibration and file
system
then there's for the audio playback
there's a third-party package that we
have to use and then some of the
internals and actually to try and
simplify
or the size of this method
there are little extension methods so
they naturally exposed the bits that you
care about uh just under each of the
folders this is in terms of a gaming
representation rather than the engine
itself but it typically Works quite well
and you you may notice here
is what I was referring to with the
scoped instance in the fact that
um every time you call a load you'll
have one battery instance that can be
accessed by everyone and therefore when
if we look here so actually
we've got a ship that owns the battery
we've then got Thruster that can consume
power from the battery and then we've
got a battery level indicator that
actually presents it on screen
in that way that means we could share
the instance across the life of the
scene and we don't have to worry about
Singletons or having to pass things
around we can still utilize the the
density injection that comes with donut
Maui
um
so we've done the registration we've
added it to here so if we then look at
in the code sample in the slide on the
code to the code sample on the slide
sorry we had a fairly simple UI
obviously I couldn't fit all of this on
the the slide it would have been really
quite difficult to read but you can then
start to see that you can construct your
UI however you see fit
there's um there's the game scene and
then we've got things overlaying on top
of the scene based on the button panel
that you can speed up and slow down
things like being able to start the game
pause the game and then there's even the
pause menu that pops up all controlled
via the stage of the game
and if we look at how we then
add it in so we've got this load scene
method again here which
loads that in for us
and then we can
respond to states in the game so they
see like we know once it's loaded then
we'll stop we'll start playing the
background music
once it started then we will um hide the
title and the play button and then we
we've got
um
as much power as we like to do there so
you can you can do animations you can do
whatever you like with because it's all
UI based
um
and as I mentioned we've got the the
ability to use all of the the.net
method so that there is quite a level of
different uh interaction events that you
can subscribe to they have better
desktop support now so you can deal with
hovering obviously you can't tell that
your fingers hovering over the
touchscreen but you can tell that the
mouse is hovering over a button
so you can build in better support for
desktops if you're if you're aiming at
building for that
then
once we've called so we called load on
our
home scene we can then look at the scene
is really quite simple I know in the sky
we actually had more codes because it's
just proving that you've got the methods
that you can interact with but in theory
uh at least in the majority of scenarios
that I've come across is that the scene
doesn't do too much it's just a
container for the the objects themselves
but it is the thing that holds the state
and it's called to to deal with the the
rendering and that the loop updates
if we then start to just look at a
slightly more complex example in terms
of
the canvas interaction so
in the ship we've got the complexity
that it's rotating around the planet so
we need to make sure that it is in the
right place
um thankfully with the beauty of the.net
Mary canvas
is the fact that we can move ourselves
around we can re reposition our origin
so actually the translate will say well
the center is now actually zero zero is
now actually in the center of the screen
rather than top left
then we can rotate the canvas and then
actually we just have to draw the the
image where we expect it to be and that
then actually drastically simplifies the
math that we need to do in order to put
something on the screen
um and then you don't have to worry
about tidying up the translation on the
rotation or any of that state once you
leave the render method that's tidied up
for you so actually you can mess around
your heart's content get yourself in a
certain position and then you won't be
affecting any other objects
that's all done for you
that's fine okay
so we've um
covered a little bit about how the book
how we can build the game then there are
some tips and tricks that I like to kind
of expose because
like I say these are pitfalls that I've
fallen into that have really quite
complicated matters
um so I like to come across a brief
example uh so if we imagine we're
controlling a ship that's flying through
space
um they say that suddenly some asteroids
are going to appear and then we need to
consider how to handle that Collision
um if they they do it here's our ship
um obviously we don't want that to
happen so if we give ourselves some guns
on the ship we've got a way to defend
ourselves uh but if we say they're not
just gonna be any guns they're gonna be
smart guns or actually when the
asteroids come into range
then um they're gonna fire
and um
then what is ultimately going to do is
going to leave us with a resource that
we can collect
uh which will be the next animation and
therefore
um you can start to see how complex this
can become really quite quickly because
if you've got a few things doing all of
this then there's a lot of stated
information in a single object
um
but we can actually split it down into
something that becomes much more simple
so what we can say is we can have a
a hull a hull that can collide with an
asteroid
then we can say that we've got a gun
that will fire when something comes into
range
um
one detail that's not on this slide is
actually the pulse colliding with the
asteroid I got so deep in the animations
that I've I don't dare go any further
um and then you've got the the resource
that can collect when it comes into the
range of the sensor and then actually
you've looked you've got
quite individual little things that do a
single task and they drastically
simplify the the implementation and and
hopefully make it easier to maintain
um to continue on with some more tips
and tricks uh
the statement update really should be
display independent so this comes into
considering what devices you're running
on
or trying to not consider what devices
you're running on effects
um if you imagine you've got a character
in the screen say you're running on a
1920x1080 screen and he's the character
is in the middle
if you then want to represent them on a
different screen if you're playing a
multiplayer game the screen size has
changed or you've on a mobile device and
it rotates you're going to run into all
manner of trouble if you're storing 960
by 540 which is the middle
uh because that's no longer the middle
so if you can store your details in
terms of really something that's
relative to the size rather than the
size itself so if we say we saw 0.5 by
0.5 you can then translate that in your
render so as long as you can separate
out update to render then you're going
to run into um
far fewer problems
like ships jumping around on a
okay when it's not supposed to
um
I don't know about yourselves but when I
play mobile games I really lack the the
positive feedback that you get from
physical buttons
not actually knowing that you're tapping
it get frustrated that you've missed it
um obviously you can't provide that
physical element but you can actually
provide some level of positive feedback
that they've actually done something so
you can put some haptic support in to
actually let them know they have clicked
on the button
um
and then you can also look at maybe
adding audio so you can add a sound so
click sounds or things like that in
terms of
the that you let them know the button
has been clicked now I will be honest
I'm quite a silent gamer my phone's
always on silence actually I don't
forget the the sound effects but the
haptic support really does make a
difference
um but it does show that there's a wide
range of different possibilities to be
able to provide positive feedback to
people there's not a one-size-fits all
for all of this
um
and then with sound effects oh sorry not
sound effects but audio in general you
can provide backing tracks for your game
as well and that will then enable to
provide a whole different element to the
game it really does make a difference
um and on that note
uh
we do actually have
sound in here as well so actually
I don't want to leave this playing in
the background while we're talking
um so you up I've changed the control
screen so you can then actually add a
little
elements that actually make it feel much
more like you're actually letting the
user know that they are doing something
and I'll meet that now so we don't go
too far
uh and the only other final Port is um
there is a lot of functionality that
comes with the tooling and the framework
so like I keep mentioning dependency
injection but there are a lot of things
that are designed to make our lives
easier and because they come without
their memory then we really want to make
sure that we make full use of them
um
this feels like it shouldn't really be a
tip and trick but um
it is a really important topic that I
always like to try and address and
highlight uh accessibility it really is
such an important topic and I think the
sheer fact of the keynote yesterday
was heavily focused on it just shows how
important it is
Maui does provide us with quite a few
tools that make it easier for us to
build a more inclusive application
and if you think that um as a really
quite crude benefit of making your
application more more inclusive is
you're opening yourselves up to a wider
range of people to install it so if
you're charging money then actually that
gives you the benefit that you might
actually make more money because you are
appealing to more people
um what it does do is it gives
another abstraction it gives us uh inter
the ability to interact with the screen
reader so any of the voiceover
assistants that come with let's say Siri
or uh
TalkBack is it with Google um
it all comes out of the box for you so
you can if you imagine that you've got a
user that's got lost in the game they
haven't actually provided any
um any input you can actually then guide
them to actually realize that they
haven't done anything and maybe you just
need to prompt them into what they need
to do
um the other thing to consider is when
we're building our applications
if we're building something that needs
to be tapped or clicked then that's most
likely that really should be a button
because that is what buttons do
um
and the other the the benefit of what Dr
Mary offers is the fact that you don't
it doesn't render the button for you it
delegates down to the platform
specifically here which is a UI button
on iOS
and apple have built in all of their
accessibility support around a UI Button
as they know what a UI button is they
know what it does and therefore the the
voiceover assistant will be able to
present that
much more clearly to a user uh there are
there will there will always be
scenarios and I think in the orbit game
you'll see that um
the pause button and the play button are
not buttons they're images
and by default images are just a static
piece of something visual that you can
look at it's not something designed to
be interacted with and therefore
um
the screen reader won't won't report
that to the user it'll it won't tell you
that you can interact with it but you
can make use of things like the semantic
properties that um
will then guide the screen reader to
report that to the user so you can
interact with this and this is what it
does and therefore ultimately that um
find its way down so that the the user
as well because it's you're guiding the
the screen reader
um actually what I really quite
I wouldn't say fun experiences uh to
turn your screen reader on and then
actually go into a game or an app that
you've got and actually realize how much
of a painful experience that becomes
um
but uh this is actually only really
scratching the surface of uh
making games and applications more
accessible uh the section at the end
there are quite a few slides and I have
sorry resources in order to help you on
that Journey
you can start to think about there's
other examples where
all right if you want to consider visual
impairment then actually there's there's
levels of contrast ratios to make sure
that your content is actually presented
to the reader so you want to make sure
between the difference between the
background and the text
is there's enough of a contrast to make
it legible
and also certain fonts and things like
that actually benefit you
and then there's other things that we
possibly could consider is that
while in games it's great to be able to
uh animate things make things move
around and Flash actually they're even
settings in iOS like reduce motion and
if that's enabled then actually we
probably shouldn't do any of that
because that's actually a bad experience
for someone rather than a good
experience
um and then I should add that the this
the sample games so in in the the orbit
repository at the moment there are three
sample games to show you how to kind of
build things there's a
a drawing game uh an air hockey game
which is mostly just a proof concept
that doesn't do too much other than
looking like a an a hockey table uh and
then there's this orbit engine
they have some level of accessibility
support in but we're surely trying to
build that up to provide a solid set of
examples in order to build something
that is inclusive
um
I've tried to talk around what the
engine does offer in order to make
people want to come and use it and
contribute to it
um but in short I wanted to cover what
it doesn't offer which is these are
mostly deliberate decisions in the fact
that you don't need us to provide you
database access you're running under.net
so therefore you can utilize whatever
you like you could use Entity Framework
sqlite Dash net
or like TV or many other services even
cloud-based databases
uh you could utilize the apis from
Essentials which we've done with the
haptic feedback or the vibration support
there's many others you can utilize
accelerometer so you can actually
introduce that for your controller
support
um as well as many other things
um and the essentials apis do refer to
them as centrals because they were that
in xamarin but they've they've been
baked into Tottenham area so they are
just part of the ecosystem
but most people just refer to them as a
central still
we can provide multiplayer support via
services like signalr or web services
um
and because both client and server will
be running.net code you can actually
share the code between the code bases
um and in fact I took part in a talk
last year where between myself in the UK
and James in the US we live stream the
drawing sample game from this Repository
uh uh and it mostly just worked with
relatively limited amounts of code
signalr is actually really quite
oppressive technology when you look at
what it's doing under the hood
um
and then there is the part that I really
like and that's having the ability to
interact with the platform specific apis
so um I did mention this briefly before
but if you've got say like I said you
wanted to implement a particle system on
your in your game or your application
you don't have to wait you don't have to
be held up by.net Maui uh you can
actually just write the functionality
yourself because you can uh interact
with DOT net for ios.net for Android and
they are bindings wrapped around the
entire
iOS or Android libraries so you've got
the full power there which you don't
have to be held up
um and then finally we mentioned uh
audio support or actually the benefits
that come with audio now audio playback
doesn't come with donut Maui it also
doesn't come with the engine but there
is a third-party package that will
enable you to do that so there are
options out there that just doesn't
necessarily come out of the box with
with what you've got here
um
testing is a tricky subject uh so don't
marry themselves they are investigating
the team are investigating how to do UI
testing
but as I say it's under investigation
so in terms of wanting I wanted to find
a way to enable people that are building
a game to be able to test their
Creations relatively straightforwardly
um
so I've tried to take the approach of
snapshot testing to some extent
um It's Not A New Concept and if
anyone's not familiar with snapshot
testing um it the the premise is is that
you write a test you
you accept the output that comes out of
it and you consider that what's called a
Golden Master and then any subsequent
test run the new output is then compared
against the the Golden Master Albert and
if there's any difference
um you'll get a failure
uh
and there can be many different types of
output for a test this one obviously is
renders an image but you could serialize
the state out to a Json or XML whatever
you like and therefore you've got
something that might be slightly more
readable in terms of when you want to
compare things certainly uh diff tools
will work better with with um
diffing text rather than an image
um this and this approach is it's quite
a crude example I mean it's not
rendering the game but it's it's aimed
at rendering something
and therefore you can then actually
prove uh what's done is is creating a
scene and then just rendering a
rectangle
um and what you'll also see I mentioned
before is that because ski is not built
into donate mirror Graphics but in this
scenario we're actually relying on skier
because it's not there's no there's no
platform for Net 7 support for the
graphics so we have to do that ourselves
so you can swap in the canvas for a
skier canvas and then you can just
render it and it'll work
uh for any eagle-eyed people in the
audience you may have noticed that this
test will fail in the next run because
there's no red circle that's being drawn
in the test in the subject under test
um I'd like to suggest that was
deliberate I'm not sure I can
um
but yeah so I mean like so you can see
that um it has potential and I think um
in terms of being able to test do the UI
testing this way it works well for
things that I have games that provide
repetitive Behavior so if you want to
test uh something like a tutorial screen
that you guarantee that people always
have the exact same experience and
something like this would work if you're
going to introduce Randomness into the
game which actually a lot of games do do
um
then you're going to run into problems
because things are not always going to
be in the same place if you look at the
asteroids they're never sworn in the
same place
um so typically when we look at that
then we'd end up serializing out to
Jason and then we can use a technique
which is known as scrubbing so you
remove the bits of detail that are
random and therefore you exclude those
from the test but if you want to verify
that a certain number of asteroids born
in this the first 10 seconds of the game
then you can still verify that but
you're actually just removing the bits
that that would actually cause the test
failure
um
the
that
the first stop on this journey I guess
is to aim to try and get something
that's reusable for everyone in terms of
when you get packaged that could be
added to a project then you could build
a game
um in terms of
getting there uh there's only five items
on the list so it can't take too long
can it uh
um the first one and I don't know about
you I really struggle with naming things
uh child one and child two we'll vouch
for that
um but someone has suggested uh the the
name of Mage which is multi-platform app
game engine which sounds quite nice I
can imagine a quite a fancy logo for
that
um
and it fits in with the technology
that's being used so that's something to
consider um
there's the investigation building in
more physics so obviously the orbit
engine deals with physics not the
engines right the orbit game deals with
physical elements
um but not all games do so like I said
there's a drawing game example that
requires no physics so we're looking at
potentially building a separate package
for that that will provide helpers in
order to simplify anything that you
think you need to build
in terms of
Diagnostics you saw we had the bounding
boxes on the screen and the hope is that
we can try to make it as easy as
possible because I've been there through
the frustrations of why is this not here
it's over there or actually quite often
you don't even know where it is because
it's out of bounds so trying to build in
levels of Diagnostics there to simplify
that I think we've all been through the
frustrations of
well we've all went to the frustrations
of trying to diagnose something that's
challenging and then things like being
able to display the frame rate on screen
things like that just just to simplify a
developer's
um
job uh we want to add in a bit of better
life cycle support So objects don't know
when they're added or create when
they're created or destroyed so actually
you can't tidy up resources particularly
efficiently at the moment
um but that's
I'm not going to say it's coming soon
hopefully it would uh it's gonna say
it's going to be trivial but uh that's a
terrible idea and then we want to
further enhance the testing support so
we've got things like the the snapshot
testing trying to investigate whether
there's other options in order to make
it far simpler because
I know when um
working on side projects testing tends
to kind of Fall by the wayside rather
than actually being a high priority
but if we can build it in and it becomes
really quite easy then
there's no excuses to
um and finally I've been I've been told
I have to present this uh when I first
told my daughters that I was building
games and going to give a talk
they became so excited they went off and
designed their own game and actually
wrote their own PowerPoint presentation
that they thought I was going to present
uh so if anyone here is interested in a
hello neighbor across with Gummy Bears
then uh that might be coming fairly soon
um and then actually just before we do
wrap up so just like we would have time
for questions uh
um there are some really great resources
that I've come across
on my journey see a smile there um so
audio jungle provides really great audio
as it suggests uh sound effects and and
music they are typically paid for but uh
they're they're not expensive and like I
said they do really make a difference
um the only thing I I discovered is that
when you they give you samples as well
so you can download it and play it they
just put um I never know what the
correct term is it's not a watermark but
they've always there's a voice over it
so make sure that you're when you're
Distributing it uh it's not painful
you can become quite used to that so
actually when you pay for it and you
remove it the the person speaking over
it it actually feels unfamiliar and
quite strange
um open gamer is a really fantastic
resource uh it's a portal for artists
that share their work it's typically
open source so depending on the license
that's up there you can use most of it
for free obviously with levels of
attribution and that covers music sound
effects graphics
a multitude of different Graphics
options and the the orbit engine uses
all of that and all of the all of a
graphical or artistic Artistry comes
from there so that's the sound effects
the music and the um
the imagery
and then there's two other great
repositories which helped Inspire this
uh there's a certain trains.net by this
man down here David
uh and then um as a Flappy Bird clone
that was built on top of skier shop by
Matthew lugowitz who maintains gear shop
um
and then that's it from me I want to
thank you very much for coming and being
a great audience to my very first ever
conference talk
um I hope it's been as much fun
listening as it has been
um talking about it uh the point I'd
like to leave on is um
I've spoken about a journey I've spoke
about this engine that I think can
potentially solve problems
I'm not going to say what's all problems
there are like I showed you in the
earlier slides
you can achieve these problems via
typical means so if you want to use a
like mvvm to build an app and there are
better applications that are suited for
it so they're a card game or things like
that you could use what you're more
familiar with you don't have to go and
learn a new piece of technology
and that's kind of where I started this
journey thinking I didn't need to and
then created a different piece of
technology which
I guess as I say it's part of the fun
part of the journey
um but I would love to see whatever
Creations people come up with and please
do reach out and suggest any suggestions
or
whatever there is
so thank you is it would anyone have any
questions or
um
uh well no sorry this is all renders
natively on its platform so actually Dr
Mario is taking care of all of that so
you can render on win UI
uh through through their drawing layer
if they've got their own
implementational menu
when we tested the windows and fire up
emulators uh so um there's
multiple ways of looking at this so you
can run unit tests
um and you can force it so in the the
code example here if I jump back
in this you can actually run this just
generally on on your on your machine you
could just run.net test and it'll
execute that for you uh there is another
piece of technology with.net Maui called
device test Runners which allows you to
um
running up on an emulator so you can
spawn these tests up onto an emulator it
is not the most pretty it kind of looks
like test Explorer on the device
and then you can run all of the tests
there but it's running it in that
environment and not just on.net seven
it's running out.net seven for Android
so you do have that power
to do that
uh
no there should in theory be a verify
method at the end that would that would
actually call that
uh so typically with Snapchat testing
you don't you don't tend to write
assertions you end up just verifying the
state of an object so what really should
have happened is it um rather than
writing the the bottom two lines would
be replaced with a verify
the scenery so you'd verify the state of
the scenery and then each time to what
so this implementation here it would
that would be inside of the verify
method and it would compare its output
to a known output
two folds on this slide
okay if there's no further questions
I just want to say thank you all again